[Applause]
for many in south africa
the global pandemic has come and gone
the people of europe may be living under
tough new restrictions
but some residents in johannesburg are
feeling less restrained
life is better now than last of last
months like
since may june july
four months ago a massive outbreak swept
through this country
infecting hundreds of thousands of
people
then quite unexpectedly the level of
infection
plummeted scientists were puzzled
some were using masks and social
distancing but it didn't explain the
drop
the only biologically plausible way for
this virus to have subsided
is that there's been some sort of herd
immunity that's been reached
but in the context of the use of
non-pharmaceutical interventions
in june scientists started testing for
the virus
in blood samples given at local clinics
and they were stunned by what they found
in cape town up to 44 of those tested
had been infected with the virus were
you surprised
by the data totally surprised and even
the models themselves
never modeled for one third of the
population getting infected
when south africa imposed its lockdown
back in march
it worked inadvertently to accelerate
the spread of covet 19.
social distancing proved impossible in
many densely populated districts
the strict level 5 lockdown in this
country was
basically a failure it didn't seem to
stop the spread of covert 19
at all but that failure had a completely
unexpected benefit which has left south
africa
in a much better position now professor
mahdi
believes 12 to 15 million people may
have developed
some immunity through repeated exposure
to the virus
and that may help south africa avoid a
second wave
but if the rate of infection does spiral
he wouldn't recommend a strict lockdown
the response needs to be much more
nuanced rather than just simply
believing that a level five la a highly
restrictive lockdown
is going to get rid of the virus and in
those circumstances
is a lockdown on its own going to
achieve
elimination of the virus in south africa
at least there are some who are ready to
celebrate
a return to relative normality john
sparks sky news johannesburg